i've been trying to talk about this
stuff in as many forums as possible for
quite some time and i think as the sort
of why i left the left guy uh i guess
i've helped wake up a whole bunch of
people on this stuff so this is june of
2018
i was on joe rogan's podcast explaining
federalism and the importance of local
control as opposed to top-down control
over your life i think there is some
utility for the state but the more i do
this the more i have these conversations
and i talk to and caps and and real
libertarians and all that
i find it hard to defend the state at
almost any level at this point but i do
think that because i don't want to live
in mad max fury road just yet although
we may be heading there i still will
defend the state at some level but i
would say everything should be local we
have an incredible experiment here with
50 states if your state taxes too high
move go somewhere else if your state
doesn't have good education you can go
somewhere else if you don't like the
weather somewhere but the second we make
everything federal and this is what it's
not just the left this is what people
who are using lazy thinking that you
referred to they think we should just
have one law that we should all live
exactly the same no matter where we are
geographically no matter what our
religion or what however we set our set
of uses that is a nightmare referring to
like it's in terms of like you want a
set of laws well because you want states
rights you you should care about estates
right so for example we live in
california we are taxed out the [ __ ]
wazoo i bought a house last year it's my
first time at 41 years old that i own
property in america i made it i own
property i don't have to tell you about
my property taxes they're insane they're
very high they're absurdly absurdly high
that's the price you pay for living in a
spot where everybody wants to live yeah
no but that's it that's the beauty right
so like there's a trade-off there now i
could move to texas and the property
taxes would be way low and maybe because
they don't tax as much the schools
aren't as good or a series of other
things but that's the beauty of the foot
vote you can go this is an experiment
this thing in america who's against that
anyone that wants to keep giving more
power to the federal government which is
pretty much everybody these days all
right so i should pat myself on the back
for that because i've been pretty
consistent in what i've been talking
about for years
as my guys were looking for that clip we
found this which was pretty kind of
funny in that i nailed exactly what was
going to happen to joe rogan you can
move your family your value whatever you
bring to your community in your life i
mean think about it right now if
california just kept taxing higher and
higher and kept screwing up a lot of
there's a ton that's going wrong in the
state eventually joe rogan might be like
you know i just built this freaking
kick-ass new studio here i'm now paying
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
taxes and all this stuff you might want
to try it somewhere else where they're
going to tax you less but that's the
beauty of the thing you don't have to
leave the country so the the federal
government should pretty much
do nothing it should make sure we're not
warring with each other that the states
aren't warring
that's about and then protect the
borders
beyond that it doesn't have to do a lot
leave it to the state dave rubin guy
who's consistently said what he thinks
and it kind of does make sense and as
long as we're doing a trip down memory
lane this is my retirement show i think
a year before that in february 2017 i
did that very famous it has now been
seen probably over 50 million times
across platforms i did that why i left
the left video that is the thing that
kind of poured rocket fuel on everything
else i was doing at the time and i
explained my rationale for not wanting
the government to intervene on anyone's
values i'm a married gay man so you
might think that i appreciate the
government forcing a christian baker or
photographer or florist to act against
their religion in order to cater
photograph or decorate my wedding but
you'd be wrong a government that can
force christians to violate their
conscience can force me to violate mine
if a baker won't bake you a cake find
another baker don't demand that the
state tell him what to do with his
private business
i'm pro-choice but a government that can
force a group of catholic nuns literally
called the little sisters of the poor to
violate their faith and pay for abortion
inducing birth control can force anyone
to do anything
that's not progressive that's regressive
last from the past when i used to say
regressive left all the time some of you
remember that uh but okay so there's
some calm rational thought and i really
am doing that not to pat myself on the
back but just to show you that there's
many people and many books
out there and many papers that have been
written of people defending what freedom
is people defending
individual rights and your ability to
make decisions over your own life and
all of those things